Welcome to top that Google today.
It's my pleasure to welcome
Millennia Abramson for room.
Okay.
Thanks for joining us today. Pleasure. Uh,
so do you mind telling us
about the film? Well, um,
so it's a film based on a novel,
the same name by this, uh,
Irish Canadian writer called Emma Donahue.
And I like to start with, I don't,
I tend to start with a little bit about
it's more fundamental thematic shape
then it's then where it
takes place because otherwise
you, everybody goes, oh no.
Um,
so for me it's a film about parenting and
it's a feeling bad being a child about
growing up. Um, but it takes
place in a very unusual context,
which I think focuses those
questions in a very particular way.
So it takes place in a locked room
for at least half of the film where,
um,
we have a mother and child and mother was
kidnapped maybe seven years before the
film starts and had a
child in that situation,
which is the one positive
thing that's come out of it.
And it's about her relationship with
that child and how she protects them from
the kind of darker aspects of,
of their,
of their world.
And it's,
it's a story that's told from the point
of view of the child for whom this is a
normal place or the
location of his childhood.
And then it tracks these people,
these two people as they get out of the
situation and as they tried to integrate
themselves back into the world. So how
did you get involved in the project?
I read the novel and she dies and
then already 2011 and I have a,
um, I had, my little boy at
that point was for nearly four.
And so it just, it sort of slayed me.
The book. I mean, it's very beautiful.
It's very moving and it's very sensitive.
Um,
and I think something of my own
feelings from my kid where, you know,
overflowed onto the
character in the novel.
And I was just fascinated by what Emma
had done and how she was talking about
these really universal things in a
situation which would normally just be a
bleak,
true crime kind of story or at worst it
could be a pretty exploitative sort of
story. Um, and I thought
I had two thoughts,
which is they were, I want to make this
into a film and quickly followed by,
I will never have a chance to make this
into your film because the novel had
been, um, had, I was a big success,
particularly in, in states. Um,
and I think while we were debating it in
the office about how we might go about
trying to get the rights,
somebody said, Oh yeah,
Obama was pictured coming out of a
bookstore in Martha's vineyard on his
vacation with a copy of this under his
arm. We just thought, well, you know,
forget it. This is way too, you know,
for a production company in Dublin.
Um, and instead of UK,
Ireland, London based company.
Um,
and,
but I just wrote this letter to Emma
because I felt so strongly about the book
and about how I thought it might work
on film that, uh, I thought, well,
at least I'm going to say what I think.
And then she can decide whether there's
anything in that. And I wrote this very,
very long ladder just sort
of talking about the novel.
I thought what the challenges were,
what I thought,
how it worked and how it
might be transposed into,
into this, to other medium.
And she replied,
and that was the beginning
of a conversation that
went on all the way through
the film.
You know,
we worked together very closely and
really lovely collaborative way, um,
um, as a kind of thing in the film
industry that you're not supposed to allow
authors to adapt their own novels because
they're going to be really precious
and they, you know, they sweated
blood over this. And so, yeah,
they're going to be awful.
It's going to be a nightmare.
And there are plenty of stories like that,
but we just kind of really got on and I
think I just trusted her and she trusted
me and that's how we worked.
He just tell they stole my next question.
And just because they do say, you know,
it's very tough to work with the screen.
Definitely. Yeah. It's
killing your darlings. Yes.
But it sounds like it
was wonderful process.
What were kind of some of
the discussion points of,
obviously you're having to tell this
story in a different media. Sure.
Some things maybe aren't gonna
translate as well as the screen.
One of the big things I thought was just,
you know,
Jack's voice is so strong and it's
so distinct in the pro style. Yeah.
Were you ever like, oh we can't tell this
from, you know, we can't do voice over,
we have to do this? Or was it
just like it has to be this? Well,
I think that there were like, I think
there were various temptations that,
and I know some pitches were made
to Emma where people said, okay,
we can use CG or we can create a kind of
like externalize the magic aspect of a
child's point of view
somehow or use a very,
very definite point of view camera.
You know, I'm not quite the Gopro,
but you know that idea that you
literally are in the boys had,
I just felt that all of
those things are wrong.
They're not native to cinema cinema
handles point of view in a very different
way. You know, it's about, and it's much
more fluid point of view in cinemas,
much more fluid. Like in a novel, there's
always a voice mediating the story.
You know, you're reading it, you're
reading it in the, the writer's voice,
whether that's first person,
third person, even if it changes,
you're always sort of with somebody.
It's a mediated thing.
Film at least in s in a sense as direct.
I mean you know,
and point of view can shift very subtly.
So you can be with a character and then
you can find yourself in even in the
same scene tuning into a different
car to just so you have that degree of
fluidity.
And my view was that with a v with some
small emphases and and inflections,
you could on a very small
use of voice over just a pin,
you to the boy at a couple of key points,
you would still be very much with him but
without having to make a huge song and
dance with it.
And also the advantage.
And then in the film in
a way over the novel,
they said it becomes more of a 200
because the mother and the novel,
she's only really seen through the eyes
of the boy. She's this idealized person.
And of course we can imagine
what she's really going through,
but it's a projection. Whereas we've
got a real breathing person in our,
in our story.
And so part of the thing
with the adaptation was to
be able to shift between his
point of view and then undercut that with
what you know she must be experiencing
in the same situation.
And part of why that's interesting is
that that actually is what happens,
I think with all parents and children
or be it in a less extreme way.
Like we turn our faces to Archie,
we turned in one face to our children,
which is this, hey, you know, good,
great to see. Everything is always,
you are telling your child with every
gesture and facial expression that
everything's great.
Sometimes you're not.
Sometimes you're shouting
at your child and you know,
in a supermarket and feeling like the
worst kind of parent in the entire
universe.
But in the in general,
you're trying to make them feel
safe and filter the world for them.
And that's sort of what room is a, is a
metaphor for it. But it comes to that.
Filtration is never fully successful.
I'm things do penetrate and aspects of
the household that you're in or if you're
kind of, if the stresses,
they will pick it up.
And moving from childhood to adulthood
is a process of the dismantling of that
membrane.
You know?
And I think in our film it just gets
dismantled in a very dramatic way.
And that just helps you think about
those things in a, in a more focused way.
Sure.
It's the stakes are kind of having to
explain to your kid maybe why the tooth
fair isn't real versus why the air entire
existence that they know is not right
on any dangerous. It's dangerous and that
they need to get out of there. Exactly.
So, I mean obviously two of the
most important factors in this film,
and it would all hinge on the actors you
have playing Jack and ma. So how did, um,
how did you guys find Brie Larson? How'd
you find Jacob Tremblay? He was so,
he's amazing.
Amazing.
Yeah. All right. He sort of still blows
my mind and I was there, you know,
and m I think with Bray,
it was one of those things
like if any film works,
there are always moments
that you look back on,
which are just pure luck because
it's such a bizarre medium.
It involves so much chaos
and uncertainty and,
and uh,
the several moments of luck for me,
one of them was that when we knew we
were really going to make the film,
we were starting to think
about casting work with a very,
very good casting director in London.
And we were thinking about it,
very short list of,
of women who we thought could
play the mother because once it,
or to be the right age, which is
mid twenties, early to mid twenties,
didn't want to be casting somebody older
and doing all the movie stuff that just
makes things feel a bit fake.
And we had maybe three names
and then somebody in the office,
actually somebody in Admin in it,
in Admin in the office said, Oh,
I saw this film called short term travel.
It's really good actor in that.
And I like e if you make films,
two things happen all the time.
One is that people come
up with scripts and um,
and the other is that people have casting
suggestions and you learn to smile and
nod politely at both and then
completely ignore them. Right. Um, and,
uh, I thought our, well great,
you know, thank you so much.
And then there happened to be a DVD lying
around the office and I took it home
and I just had a bit of time
that night and I watched it.
And She's absolutely staggering. Bria,
staggering in that film. And she's,
she's interesting because she's both
dramatically incredibly strong and you can
go very deep,
but she also has this lightness and she
inhabits her characters without any of
that showy,
you know,
tragic heroine intensity that would just
kill this film because you've got to
believe that she's a real person that
would have been on any street in any
American town. And I was just
unlucky. Um, so I went on,
I met her and I met a couple of the other
people that we were interested in and
she just, yeah, I started
a conversation where,
or not meeting that we just continued
through one audition and it just felt like
I didn't want that conversation to,
and you know, and then with Jake,
when you're casting a child,
you give yourself a time limit.
So if it's a small child, you
can't sort of say, well we'll,
we'll cast the child and then
when we know we've got the child,
because otherwise if we don't
have the drive and have a film,
we'll then start putting the film
together because we know we're okay.
Problem is that's going to take you a year
and then the child would have changed.
So it's this weird,
it's like cooking a dinner and trying to
get everything to be ready at the same
time you have to get on
with the film. Uh, you know,
setting it up and you get on
with looking for the kid. So I,
and I used to say to Emma and
would say, you know, well,
what if we don't find the
kid? And all right. And I'd
say, Oh, you know, you know,
there's top professionals
working on there. So, you
know, we do this all the time.
But actually of course there was this
terrible fear that we wouldn't find our
boy and then we would have to postpone
and all that. And then Jake put them,
he was put on tape by
his parents in Vancouver.
And I saw his tape and it was really good.
Maybe a little bit,
he'd done some commercials and stuff.
So there was a little bit of that sweet
kind of, you know, being kind of acting,
which it, which is fine if you're
selling toothpaste or a car insurance,
but if you put it in a real film, the kid
just looks like Kotick, you know, that,
that sort of way.
So when I went to meet him,
met him in La and with a few other
little boys and it's weird auditioning to
little kids cause they're all gorgeous
and you don't want to sit there going,
yeah, you know, get rid of that one. But,
but it's just, it's who fits the thing.
You know. And Jake had that lovely, uh,
he's very natural kid. His parents are
not showbizzy at all. Um, he loves acting.
Uh, and uh, very quickly could see that,
that we could take that
layer of sweetness away.
And I just wanted to see, can I make him
comfortable? Not pretending, you know,
another was just sitting there.
And what is it,
what's it like if I ask them
just to sit there and you know,
holds a look and then look away and look
back. And that's when you see, does it,
does the, the little guy, when
you ask them to do something,
does he then do it with a natural
kind of comfort? You know,
and he does a course. He's still very
young and, and it involves, you know,
getting that performance out
of him involved on both sides.
So much kind of effort. And I'm Brea as
well because Bree was so much part of,
in the scenes, he was really
helping him and she'd of, she'd say,
stop kicking your leg against the
table or, you know, move your hair,
or remember what Lenny said
about this or she was amazing.
And then she'd be able to go right
back into her, her performance.
But Jake has it.
And if he didn't have it,
we wouldn't do it just would be no film.
I'm curious in terms of
working with the two actors,
because Bree kind of has to be in this
very horrible, not horrible, but she,
you know,
she'll broken downstate versus Jake who
in the beginning needs to be kind of
just like, hey the world
is, the world is, yeah.
Did that affect your
production schedule at all?
Did you guys try and shoot
prep with ray first and then,
and then bring Jake in fresh or what? We
prep a Bri from the moment she was cast,
that was about eight months.
So we shot and I was in contact with
her a lot and was over and back to
California a lot. And um, so and,
and talking about the couch cause,
cause like I say, the character
isn't fully formed in the novel.
So there was loads of room and Bri was,
but she was getting on with our own prep
and we were talking and she was going
on with our own prep.
So she,
and she got herself really into the
right state of mind by the time we were
ready to shoot. But then Jake arrived
and it's just like in the film,
nothing will dampen his spirits. I
mean, so it doesn't matter how kind of,
what she's been going into in
preparation, he's going, hey,
what's your favorite star wars character?
And you know,
look if I held your nose and you'd
do my, you know, it's just like,
you can't stop him.
He's this little lovely little boy.
And that was actually really good
I think for her because it stopped.
It stopped her being able to sync.
She had to come back up and
come back up between takes.
And there's some lovely moments like, you
know, I don't know who's seen the film,
but there's a moment where
they're reunited at the,
after they'd been kidnapped.
It's very, very emotional after they've
escaped is incredibly emotional.
Brie is absolutely, you
know, it is one of the most,
it was amazing piece of work from
her. She's just, she's crying,
she's sobbing and it's real.
You know,
she's got herself into that state
and I'd call cut and j could go,
why you still crying? You know, Lenny
cold cut, what's wrong? You know,
let's hang out. What do you want to
eat from the craft service table? So,
so it was just brilliant because it just,
it kept everybody from taking
themselves too seriously. Um,
what sort of research did you,
did you do, did you have Bree do,
did she kind of take this on our own?
Um,
I believe Emma had said when
she was writing the novel,
at least she didn't get too bogged down
in it just because unfortunately there
are so many real life kind of examples
of this that you don't want it to become
too much of one story. And also you,
it's always imagine an [inaudible],
whatever the word is because the
research brings you a certain distance,
you know,
can give you a lot of the,
I was quite interested in small
things like you know, what,
how do the police operate afterwards?
What are the media do,
what are the kinds of,
what are the beats of all those things?
Just so that it feels real. And I
find those some footage of, you know,
arrivals home to houses really useful.
And I read interviews and watched
interviews. But the thing about,
the thing about it is people don't,
you know,
none of us speak unless you're,
unless that's your thing.
None of us speak with great insight about
ourselves. I don't think we do anyway.
You know, and people stories become
a bit calcified so that after that,
when you see a story, it's sometimes
already become a kind of bit of a uh,
a potter,
you know?
So in the end you've really got to
imagine what was it really like the moment
when they stopped at what,
you know,
you have no choice but to do the thing
that you always do if you're making a
running book or making a film and just
try your best to get inside it using your
own, you know, your own resources.
But I know, I know I did. I did.
Yeah, I did read some of the stuff and
watch some of the stuff from particular
interested in the media and how the
media exploit's those people and what it,
all those interviews feel like.
And because we were doing one
of those interviews in the film,
it was a brilliant thing to be able to
watch those simpering deeply concerned,
heavily quaffed people who,
whose make that, you know,
who have that dripping sense of deep
concern and you just know that it is.
There is a savage ratings getting
machine operating under that.
So that was it. Useful to watch.
That's one of the things I noticed, um,
that is also pretty prominent in the book.
Where do you think this film
kind of would've resonated
maybe 50 years ago where
we weren't in this 24 seven media cycle
where it's almost this like horrific
expectation of these people are victims.
That's right.
It will have to participate
in an interview and then
it's like if they don't,
people are like, well, what's
wrong with you? You know, my,
and I had to be private about it.
It's like all the people
cheering when they come home.
And what makes you think that that's what
these people who've just been through
this terrible trauma need?
I mean,
I'm not suggesting that people
cheering don't actually feel something,
but everything is a spectacle.
And I don't think 30,
40 years ago,
this would be an entirely different film.
And you would actually imagine
that largely people would keep,
this is also not necessarily a good thing,
but people would want to keep it quiet
because it'd be perceived shame and,
and all that around what had happened.
Now at least that's not there now.
Although we are, you know, it's
very interesting, you know,
that whole idea of how we, how shame
operates in, in the public's fair now and,
and how ticketing social media that
that kind of mob can form really,
really quickly. Um, and it's
the same I think in these cases.
People end with the parts over them, judge
the mother. Um, and when she comes out,
she is so concerned to show that
she's done a good job with the boy.
That's very, I think that's something
very sad about that. It is. And I think,
I think it's probably one
of the crucial things,
my understanding is you could say to
a parent is like judging them on their
parenting style and saying,
you know, well it shouldn't,
shouldn't you've done this.
It's like, well you don't know,
you weren't in my shoes. That's where
I didn't even have shoes. Yeah. Um,
so I'm curious about religion just because
it is a little more prominent in the
book, but I don't think it was
missing from the movie. But I'm,
I'm curious as to what the decision was
in terms of not making it this kind of
huge factor. I just didn't
want it to be, I mean,
in a way I didn't want it
to be appropriated by that
constituency has that kind
of story. I just an Emma what
Emma did and then all of that,
she does bring in a little bit
of it and then it's really just,
it's Mars attempt to use
whatever materials she's got
to make this work for the
boy and I, I felt what, I don't think
anybody needed this. I'm, I'm myself,
I'm not religious. I'm it. And I'm
pretty kind of emphatic about that.
So I suppose it's just a personal thing.
She just talk about heaven,
but that's a very generic idea.
But as soon as you talk about
God and Jesus and stuff, um,
I just,
for me it rang alarm bells and I just
didn't want the film being talked about as
a cause.
I think people should believe whatever
they want and be totally free to do that.
But in this story,
for me it is the actual love of a mother,
which all mothers, um, you know,
most people give to their children
regardless of whether they're religious or
not. And I thought, well, if
you could do it without that,
then let's do it without it.
I definitely kind of enjoyed that.
It made it more accessible to me is
also like a Christian or whatever. Yeah.
Where it's, it's, it's just
more her appropriating the
backstories and mythology.
She already knows that as
opposed to, uh, you know,
making it about a specific.
Exactly. Um, so when, uh,
one of the things I really enjoyed, and
this is just more of a film making thing,
was that the use of sound and music and
then the kind of lack thereof. Yeah. Um,
I don't think we even heard music at all
until we kind of went into Jack's first.
Yeah,
there's a little bit,
but really the first proper score
is Wimmer in his first voiceover.
Was that something that you knew from
the beginning that you just want it to be
this like cold? No, the music
thing is always organic with me.
I worked with the same composer.
He's what I've worked on every,
with everything that I've done.
He did frank as well,
but the songs on the soundtrack and I,
we've been friends since we were in
the Irish equivalent of third grade,
like we were nine, so that, right.
That's that then isn't it? And um,
we always just, it's always a thing
that he just starts coming in,
starts watching stuff,
starts to put pieces against
what we're doing and we see them,
we keep them where we, we, we lays them.
And I think I'm always pretty sparing
with music because I think it's when a
film can do a lot of it's work,
just easing those very simple tools.
That's a very strong thing.
And then when you do use music,
it has more effect because it isn't
just this wallpaper that's there all the
time. Um, sound, I think it's a
really good sound job on this film.
We spent a lot of time on it and just
that feeling of opening out when the door
opens and,
and you just get this and you realize
that you've been in this kind of vacuum
space for,
for a while.
And then once they're outside and Jack
is having to deal with the kind of
buzzing confusion of the world.
There's quite a lot of very good,
very separate design that just emphasizes
different frequencies and just masses
a little bit with perspective in the same
way that the camera starts to be, um,
to deconstruct a little bit. Some
of those experiences, like when,
when he's with the police and they're
asking him questions in the way that a
child does, he's, his attention is just
as likely to be focused on the barges,
the face, you know, where the
heart is, the face and, and, um,
and those are the things we didn't really
do inside the room where everything is
familiar. So yeah, sound
design is, uh, you know,
it's a huge part of it and just personal
grievance is that so many theatres are
bodily set up and they also play that
film's really quietly because they don't
want, they use a huge big
blockbusters which leak into the sea,
send them into the theater,
right beside if it's a multiplex and
see half the time when you're watching a
subtle film,
you're losing massive amount of its
impact because it's not an immersive sound
experience, it's just that
it's just a bit too quiet. Um,
only heard it in properly and,
and good, but lack of sound.
That I think was the thing that was most,
we heard the least the most. Um, um,
so I think one of my
favorite scenes personally,
at least it was when they're out and my,
or joy or she's just like,
I want him to connect with
something. Yes. Um, you know,
and clearly he's actually capable
of, and she's not, but I'm,
I'm curious as to what you
want people to connect with.
Like what's one of the things you want
people to connect with most with this
film? Um, for me it's always,
it's a good way of asking it
because people usually say,
what do you want people to take away?
Or what ideas do you
want them to take away?
But I don't think in terms so much of,
of ideas and there are lots of ideas and
it's quite a fertile film for thinking
about things via, you know, but, um,
I think more about experiences
and a kind of film is such a,
it can be, especially in the theater,
is such a kind of completely,
I use that word again, immersive
experience that it, it, it,
it sometimes allows you
to open up a little bit,
just very simply about the relationships
in your own life. For Poor, for me,
it's to feel more a different kind of
empathy or a or a an awareness of other
people. And I, for me, it's, it's, I hope
that you feel that you've had a very,
very intimate encounter with
people that you've cared about.
And I think through art,
those encounters are pure in a way that
they can never be in life because it's
almost impossible in life to distance
yourself from your own requirements or
impulses or once in a given situation
or there was, were, were actors in,
in our own lives and we can,
it's very hard to abstract that probably
with your own children is the only time
where you feel that,
you know,
that lack of yourself being
that important. But, but for me,
I think a good piece of film or humanistic
piece of film is one that sharpens
your sense of empathy and, and, and
does it in this crucible of a, of a,
of an experience in this,
in the theater.
But then maybe you
bring that back out and,
and it just opens you up a little bit.
Um,
so I think my last question is,
and we're going to be taking audience
questions if anyone wants to line up, um,
what was the most challenging thing about
making this film for you and what was
the most rewarding thing?
Probably the most challenging was,
was was how do you preserve the,
the tension in the film after
the escape because you have a,
an escape sequence in the middle of
the film, which would normally be the,
you know,
the climax of a film and then you're
going to move on into this different sort
of question that you're
asking in the second half.
And I think in way we found just by,
but by making something of
the anticlimax of the escape,
make that the plot point that for an
ordinance goes, oh wait, this isn't,
this isn't going to be this sudden
realization that it's not going to be what
you were hoping for.
And also,
I suppose certain kind of very focused
storytelling in the second half,
which just creates this, I
don't know, just this, this,
this tension around whether
the relationship can survive.
And probably the bit,
the most rewarding thing about it was,
um,
actually just feeling the audience's
reaction to you. What, I mean,
that's not so much about the
making, but I've made it, you know,
if this is my fifth feature and
they've all had, you know, they've,
I'm very lucky there will be well reviewed
and I've gone to very good festivals
and first two to three were very art
house films and you get an extremely
attached audience for those.
But,
but it's a small one and in a
big room for a lot of people.
It's just not what they want.
And,
and I didn't go out making this film
in order to, that wasn't the purpose.
I didn't want to go and say I'm going
to make abroad and clap crowd pleasing
film. I wanted to make the right
that the film that this should be.
But when it turns out
that that actually has a,
a much bigger audience and not, the
effect is so emotional, sort of amazing.
I mean in, in Toronto, I, Eh,
I didn't go to the screening,
but I came,
I came at the end and I heard the music
start on this absolutely huge response
from the audience. And then I walked out
and there was a massive innovation and,
uh, that was sort of overwhelming. It
was, but it was, it was really lovely.
Yeah. Um, do we have any,
I feel like it's a shareholder's meeting.
Uh,
was there any part of the book that you
wanted to adapt for the film and we're
not able to, yes, there were some
parts of the book that I really loved.
I think again,
in the second half there's a trip to
the shopping mall that they go on.
My has a brother in the book. We, we,
she, he's not there in the film. Um,
and they go to the shopping mall and
Jack is dragged around and it doesn't
understand anything and
it's all overwhelming.
It's a really lovely commentary
on the way we live. Um,
but in the film,
it was only by really focusing the
film in this very laser like way in the
second part where you aren't entirely
tracking the relationship with the mother
and son. That's, so I shot,
I did shoot a shopping mall scene and
it's really interesting and on its own is
very interesting,
but,
and it also took them out of the house
at the end and I felt, no, let's,
you know,
let's keep this balance.
It's one interior to another
via this big expansive section.
And so I kept it up at
that. Thank you. Thank you.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us today. It's a pleasure.
Thank you so much for coming.
[inaudible].